how could jane foster choose a life of
superheroics over her lifelong passion
was this magical weapon always available
to those who don't prove themselves
worthy and what makes thor a hero
instead of just a god these are the
confusing moments in thor love and
thunder explain major spoilers ahead
gore and his daughter are the first
people seen in thor love and thunder as
they walk through a barren desert dying
of starvation and thirst all of this
sets up the story of how gore loses his
faith and becomes the god butcher
however because gore and his daughter
appear to be human viewers may be
confused as to whether the scene takes
place on earth while the movie doesn't
provide an explanation the comics offer
some clues
in the comics gore is more obviously
alien in his design and his loss of
faith explicitly happens on an alien
planet with that we can safely assume
that movie gore is also an alien when
the prologue takes place is more
difficult to answer love and thunder
leaves this to viewers imaginations
however in the comics gore lost his
faith thousands of years ago and even
meets thor for the first time in the
middle ages while thor doesn't encounter
gore until the present day in the movie
based on the comics it's fair to believe
that gore has been on his god-killing
quest for centuries if not millennia
after hella shattered thor's hammer
mjolnir into pieces at the beginning of
ragnarok thor needed a new weapon to
take on thanos and infinity war so with
the help of some of the guardians of the
galaxy he traveled to nidavelir to ask e
tree the dwarf to forge stormbreaker for
him thor and his allies then heroically
flew in mid-battle to join the fight
against thanos on earth and thor
demonstrated the awesome power of his
shiny new weapon stormbreaker remains
thor's weapon of choice in his latest
adventure but when jane shows up
wielding mjolnir stormbreaker exhibits
all the signs of being jealous of thor's
close relationship with his ex-weapon
while it's a hilarious take on a love
triangle some viewers may find
themselves wondering why stormbreaker
seems sentient while mjolnir never did
the answer has been supplied by thor
love and thunder director taika waititi
who pointed out that the axe's handle
was made out of groot's arm groot is
currently a teenager making his former
arm a teenager too because of its
connection to groot not only does
stormbreaker have a certain level of
consciousness like many teenagers it's
also fairly temperamental
jane and thor fell in love during 2011's
thor but after breaking the bifrost they
didn't see each other again until two
years later in thor the dark world after
that jane and thor embarked on a romance
but as korg explains in love and thunder
soon fear and their commitment to their
jobs led to their breakup sorry to hear
that jane dumped you
she didn't dump me you know
i dumped her mutual dumping while it's
not entirely clear when this happened we
know jane and thor were no longer
together by ragnarok and their reunion
offers an opportunity for further
clarity when thor and jane meet again
jane casually asks how long they've been
apart what's the family three four years
eight years seven months and six days
give or take some fans may be confused
about why the discrepancy between their
recollections of the timing of their
breakup is so different but there are a
couple of potential explanations on the
one hand it points to the fact that thor
has been literally counting the days
since they parted while jane has had
other things on her mind that would
indicate thor's been holding a much
bigger and brighter torch for jane than
she has for him however jane's belief
that it's been somewhere between three
and four years might suggest she may
have been snapped away by thanos meaning
that in her mind their breakup is far
more recent than it is for thor because
for five of the eight plus years since
she technically didn't exist is it a
subtle nod that
actions or are we reading too much into
things you decide
thor love and thunder introduces several
new locations but perhaps the most
impressive is omnipotence city an
embassy for gods of all kinds from
across the universe yet while all gods
are welcomed there in the comics that
isn't the case in the film thor
indicates that their attendance at the
meeting of gods where they plan to ask
for zeus's help to take on gore is by
invitation only in fact they're so
concerned about getting kicked out
before they can make their request that
they don the clothes of a set of gods
that were invited as a disguise still
it's hard not to wonder why thor hasn't
been invited to omnipotence city before
after all he's a god from a pretty
powerful family that's made waves across
the nine realms moreover in the comics
thor once went to omnipotence city to
seek information about gore's
whereabouts from its vast library yet
while his destination in the movie is
the same thor is not exactly welcome in
the mcu's version of omnipotence city in
fact while thor may seem like a big deal
in other contexts
zeus indicates he doesn't think too
highly of the space viking noting that
once odin died he was under the
impression his whole pantheon was gone
in the comics the denizens of olympus
and asgard are usually friends and
allies of course there are always
exceptions but it seems that there's not
a whole lot of good will between the two
pantheons in the mcu perhaps that's why
thor has never landed an omnipotence
city invite before
when we first meet thor more than a
decade ago he reveled in war and sought
out fights even when there was no need
through your arrogance and stupidity
you've opened these peaceful realms and
innocent lives to the horror
and desolation of war but after odin
stripped him of mjolnir and banished him
to earth thor learned his lesson his
ability to help people was his true
superpower it was this realization that
led him to join the avengers and become
a defender of earth and its people yet
the other gods we meet and love and
thunder don't seem to share thor's
concern for the greater good in love and
thunder the gods come across as vain and
complacent and they believe mortal
beings only purpose is to worship them
this is a bit confusing after all thor
is nothing like these other gods part of
the reason for this may be simply that
thor's viking background means he was an
especially talented fighter and it gave
him a skill that he could use to benefit
others a skill that many other gods may
not share that said gods like zeus used
to be powerful forces on earth but
aren't anymore it's possible that just
as their worshippers have rejected them
they've turned against their former
worshipers however it's more likely that
thor is so different from the other gods
directly because of his humbling
experiences on earth once he realized
that human beings could be worth
protecting he became a true hero instead
of just a god it doesn't seem as if the
other gods in omnipotence city have had
the same humbling moments
when thor gets the attention of zeus in
omnipotence city and asks him to raise
an army of gods to help him take on gore
zeus is unwilling to help arguing that
the gods are safe where they are the
only measure he's willing to take to
protect the gathered deities from gore
is to force thor and his allies to stay
there so gore can't learn the location
of omnipotent city from them yet some
fans may scratch their heads at this not
because zeus's reason for holding thor
is flawed but because if he wants to
keep thor in omnipotence city he should
want to do the same with every other god
in existence after all if thor knows
where omnipotence city is it stands to
reason that all the other gods do too
so even if zeus doesn't want to take on
gore if he wants to ensure none of the
god's gore goes after reveals the
location of omnipotence city it seems he
should send someone to gather up any
gods who aren't already there that way
the gods will all be safe in omnipotence
city and gore will never learn their
location it's a win-win and since thor
is the only god who seems to want to
confront gore zeus probably wouldn't get
much pushback to keeping all the gods in
the city
when zeus tries to have his soldiers
take thor and his friends into custody
so they can't leave omnipotent city it
leads to a brutal brawl yet despite all
the gods surrounding them the only one
that helps the soldiers is zeus zeus
wreaks plenty of havoc with his weapon
thunderbolt including almost
obliterating court when he attempts to
take thor out with it though thor
catches it and throws it back at zeus
seemingly landing a killing blow to the
shock of the other gods watching despite
appearing to meet his demise however
it's revealed in a mid-credits scene
that although zeus was wounded he's far
from deceased this could lead some to
wonder if zeus can truly die at all zeus
is still alive in the comics so there's
no definitive evidence one way or
another plus we know that regardless of
how poetic it might have been zeus's own
weapon can't kill him which likely means
no other divine weapon can either
however even though zeus is unwilling to
seek out gore for the good of gods
everywhere his attempt to prevent thor
from going after him so gore can't
discover the location of omnipotence
city indicates he's scared of gore's
weapon the necrosort so while it may be
almost impossible for zeus to die it
seems there's at least one weapon in the
universe that can kill him
after gore takes up the necrosword it
grants him all kinds of powers that
ironically mimic those of a deity gore
is immortal as long as the sword exists
has enhanced strength that allows him to
overcome gods and is able to create
shadow monsters that do his bidding yet
it's only when thor mighty thor and
valkyrie reach the shadow realm where
gore resides that we see he possesses
one more unexpected skill the ability to
read minds when the trio initially
arrives the god butcher is nowhere to be
found and when he finally appears he's
like something out of a horror movie as
he immobilizes them and then taunts them
with their darkest memories impulses and
feelings while his ability to use each
individual's own thoughts against them
makes gore even scarier than he already
was it's hard not to wonder where this
particular power comes from in the
comics the necro sword granted gore
plenty of abilities but telepathy wasn't
one of them yet earlier in love and
thunder the necro sword appears to have
the power to not only call out to gore
but to know that he would be a worthy
successor to the individual who
previously wielded it this indicates
that at least in the mcu the necro sword
grants its user the ability to see into
others minds it may not be the most
useful skill when your goal is to slay
gods but it's sure freaky when gore uses
it to torture thor and his allies in the
movie
where were you
where were you outside of a brief
appearance in in-game jane hasn't been
seen in the mcu in almost a decade and
when we catch up with her in love and
thunder she isn't in a good place jane
has advanced stage cancer and even
though she's getting treated for it it
isn't getting better nonetheless jane
continues to work even sleeping in her
lab so she can get more done while the
movie suggests that part of what jane is
doing centers on finding a cure for her
cancer it's reasonable to assume she's
still pursuing the astrophysics work
that was established as her passion
early in the thor franchise yet after
she travels to asgard reconnects with
mjolnir and becomes the mighty thor jane
completely abandons her life's work to
travel across the cosmos and fight gore
while the movie doesn't put to find a
point on it some viewers may feel this
seems out of character for jane whose
brilliant mind balanced thor's
spectacular brawn in the first two thor
films ultimately the reason behind her
changed focus is supplied by jane
herself the cancer is making jane feel
weak and incapable but picking up
mjolnir and becoming the mighty thor
makes her feel strong and powerful to
jane it's like she's been granted
another life so if her choices are only
to continue to pursue her physics work
until she's too weak to do so anymore or
to periodically feel strong as the
mighty thor it's understandable why
she'd choose the second option let's
bring the rainbow
throughout its time in the mcu mjolnir
has never demonstrated the same level of
sentience that stormbreaker does in love
and thunder nonetheless it's clear
mjolnir knows how to listen not only
does it refuse to let the god of thunder
reclaim it on odin's orders in the first
thor film but in his fourth solo
adventure when thor tells mjolnir to
always protect jane while the pair are a
couple the hammer clearly takes the
instructions to heart so when jane's
cancer doesn't appear to be improving
mjolnir calls to her from new asgard and
once she arrives it puts its shattered
remains back together and grants her the
power of thor
yet it soon becomes clear that wielding
mjolnir is actually accelerating jane's
cancer as a doctor on new asgard tells
thor jane is rapidly declining and it
seems her taking up the mantle of the
mighty thor is the reason but this is a
confusing revelation after all if
mjolnir's goal is to protect jane how is
it possible that it's actually making
things worse for her unfortunately
mjolnir's options for helping jane are
pretty much limited to granting her
superhero powers in the comics when jane
uses mjolnir to become the mighty thor
it removes all toxins from her body
including the chemotherapy and other
drugs treating her cancer while leaving
cancer behind because it's a part of her
so while it's doing the best it can to
keep jane safe mjolnir doesn't realize
its form of protection won't actually do
much to assist a terminally ill human
it's a reasonable oversight when you're
used to being wielded by space vikings
but it hastens jane's sad end
ever since thor was introduced in the
mcu a major part of his story has
centered on whether he was worthy of
wielding mjolnir as a result it's
understandable that when he was forced
to switch weapons many fans believed
that same worthiness clause applied to
his newly forged axe stormbreaker after
all stormbreaker certainly seems to be
as powerful as mjolnir in many ways so
these same fans may be very confused
when the seemingly unworthy gore is able
to take stormbreaker from thor and carry
it off with him in love and thunder but
it won't be the first time fans have
wondered if characters have to be worthy
to lift stormbreaker the question was
raised after groot lifted the axe to
offer his arm as a handle in infinity
war with that film's directors joe and
anthony russo clarifying mjolnir
requires worthiness not stormbreaker in
fact even mjolnir didn't require
worthiness until odin whispered the
words that gave it this property
considering that it makes sense that
pretty much anyone can lift stormbreaker
if they want to
the necrosword has granted gore an
unnaturally long life but that longevity
has come with a trade-off if the
necrosword is ever destroyed gore will
die quickly afterward so when thor
returns to the shadow realm to rescue
asgard's children and once again attempt
to defeat gore his main goal is to
shatter the necrosort thor manages to
get this done with an assist from the
kidnapped asgardian kids who he
temporarily shares his powers with and
jane who he'd begged to stay on new
asgard as another fight as mighty thor
is likely to kill her despite the demise
of the necrosword gore still opens the
doors to eternity before he dies which
was his goal all along in love and
thunder eternity is a being at the
center of the universe who will grant
the individual who finds it a single
wish and even though he's dying gore
still has enough life in him to see his
plan through to the end thor and jane
follow him into eternity where jane
collapses and thor admits gore has won
yet it's not clear why it has to be that
way after all gore no longer has the
power of the necrosword so it seems thor
could easily kill him before he made his
wish saving himself in the process plus
with gore out of the way presumably
gore's wish would pass to thor and he
could wish jane's cancer away saving her
and enabling them to pursue their
rekindled romance instead the pair
convinces gore to wish for his daughter
to live instead of all gods to die which
ensures thor's survival believes jane to
perish why would thor choose to spare
the life of his enemy instead of killing
him in cold blood well as he says in
thor ragnarok because that's what heroes
do
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]